>>> NEW THIS MORNING TEXT
MESSAGES OBTAINED BY CNN
REVEALED THAT A KEY FIGURE IN
THE PLOT TO OVERTURN THE 2020
ELECTION BRIEFED WHITE HOUSE
CHIEF OF STAFF MARK MEADOWS
ABOUT HIS ATTEMPTS TO GAIN
ACCESS TO VOTING MACHINES IN
BATTLE GROUND STATES.
JOINING ME NOW CNN NATIONAL
SECURITY REPORTER ZACHARY COHEN.
ZACH, THIS SHOWS THE PRESIDENT'S
CHIEF OF STAFF KNEW ABOUT THESE
EFFORTS.
>> JIM, IT'S REMARKABLE.
THESE ARE TEXTS BETWEEN MEADOWS
AND PHIL WALDRON.
HE WAS BEHIND SOME OF THE MOST
OUTLANDISH PROPOSALS OF
OVERTURNING THE ELECTIONS AND
GETTING ACCESS TO VOTING
MACHINES.
HE WAS HUNG ON THIS IDEA THAT
FOREIGN ADVERSARIES HAD HACKED
INTO VOTING MACHINES THROUGH
OUTLANDISH WAYS.
>> BASED ON NOTHING.
>> BASED ON NOTHING, SATELLITES,
THERMOSTATS, HE WAS ON A MISSION
TO PROVE IT.
THIS SHOWS THAT MARK MEADOWS WAS
TALKING TO PHIL WALDRON, A
DIRECT LINE TO TRUMP'S CHIEF OF
STAFF AT A TIME WHEN TRUMP'S
ALLIES WERE URGENTLY HUNTING FOR
IN I PROOF OR EVIDENCE OF VOTING
YOU HAD FRAUD THAT THEY NEVER
DID TURN UP.
I THINK THE TIMING OF THIS IS
IMPORTANT.
IT'S INTERESTING TO NOTE WHAT
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE IS
NOT NECESSARILY ILLEGAL, BUT
WHAT IT IS IS SHOWS JUST THE
SENSE OF URGENCY FROM THE TRUMP
PEOPLE TO REALLY PROVE THE
CONSPIRACIES THAT WERE OUT
THERE.
>> HOW DID MEADOWS RESPOND WHEN
HE WAS MADE AWARE OF THIS?
>> IN BOTH INSTANCES HE RESPONDS
IN ONE WORD.
IN THE FIRST EXAMPLE THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT AN EFFORT TO GET
VOTING MACHINE ACCESS IN ARIZONA
AND A JUDGE SAYS, NO, WE ARE NOT
GOING TO LET THAT HAPPEN.
WALDRON IS INFORMING MEADOWS
ABOUT THIS.
WHEN HE DOES MEADOWS SAYS ONE
THING, HE SAYS PATHETIC.
>> HE WASN'T SATISFIED WITH THE
EFFORTS.
>> HE CLEANLY MAKES HIS
FEELINGS --
>> THERE IS A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION AT BOTH THE STATE
AND FEDERAL LEVEL, SO
INVESTIGATIONS I SHOULD SAY INTO
OBTAINING VOTING MACHINES
POTENTIALLY ILLEGALLY.
SO THAT IS A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION NOW.
>> JIM, LOOK, THERE IS STATE AND
FEDERAL INVESTIGATIONS, CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS INVOLVING
INCIDENTS IN THREE DIFFERENT
STATES.
IT'S NOT CLEAR AND THERE IS NO
EVIDENCE THAT IT'S DIRECTLY
RELATED TO WHAT WALDRON IS
TALKING TO MEADOWS ABOUT IN
THESE TEXT MESSAGES BUT IT'S
INTERESTING BECAUSE SEVERAL OF
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE TARGETS
OF THESE CRIMINAL INVESTIGATIONS
ARE ALSO ASSOCIATES OF WALDRON
AND HAVE WORKED WITH HIM IN THE
PAST.
THOSE INVESTIGATIONS HAVE TO
PLAY OUT, BUT THE OVERLAP THERE
IS NOTABLE.
>> INVESTIGATIONS HAVE TO PLAY
OUT.
THAT IS A FAMILIAR MANTRA.
ZACH COHEN, THANKS FOR THE
REPORTING.
THANKS SO MUCH.
>>> IN A NEW INTERVIEW A FORMER
SENIOR TECHNICAL ADVISER TO THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE, DENVER
RIGGLEMAN, SAYS THAT THE WHITE
HOUSE PLACED A PHONE CALL TO A
CAPITOL RIOTER ON THE DAY OF THE
INSURRECTION.
>> WE GET A REAL AH-HA MOMENT
WHEN YOU SEE THAT THE WHITE
HOUSE SWITCHBOARD HAD CONNECTED
TO A RIOTER'S PHONE WHILE IT'S
HAPPENING.
>> SOMEONE IN THE WHITE HOUSE
WAS CALLING ONE OF THE RIOTERS
WHILE THE RIOT WAS GOING ON?
>> ON JANUARY 6.
ABSOLUTELY.
>> JOINING ME NOW CNN LEGAL
ANALYST JENNIFER RODGERS.
I'M CURIOUS THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
THIS HERE.
TO HAVE A COMMUNICATION BY THE
WAY AN OUTGOING CALL FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE TO A RIOTER I
BELIEVE FOR A HANDFUL OF SECONDS
BUT STILL A CORRECTION THERE.
WHAT SIGNIFICANCE DO YOU SEE
POTENTIALLY?
I KNOW YOU DON'T HAVE DETAILS OF
WHO PLACED THE CALL AND WHAT WAS
THE CONTENT BUT POTENTIAL
SIGNIFICANCE OF THAT LINK.
>> WELL, IT WOULD BE, OF COURSE,
A COMMUNICATION BETWEEN THE
WHITE HOUSE AND THE RIOTERS,
WHICH SUGGESTS POSSIBLE
COORDINATION.
I MEAN, THERE IS A LOT WE DON'T
KNOW, OF COURSE, WHO PLACED THE
CALL, THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
DO SOME DETECTIVE WORK TO FIGURE
OUT IF THEY CAN WHO PLACED THAT
CALL FROM INSIDE THE WHITE
HOUSE, BUT THEN YOU START TO
THINK ABOUT WHAT COORDINATION
WAS THERE BETWEEN PEOPLE ON THE
GROUND WHO WERE BREACHING THE
CAPITOL AND THE WHITE HOUSE AND
OF COURSE LOOKING BACK TO SEE
WHETHER THERE ARE OTHER
COMMUNICATIONS EARLIER IN THAT
DAY AND THE DAYS PRECEDING
JANUARY 6.
>> OKAY.
SO THE OTHER NEW REPORTING FROM
MY COLLEAGUE ZACH COHEN WE WERE
JUST DISCUSSING AND THAT IS TEXT
MESSAGES.
WE DO KNOW WHO WAS ON BOTH SIDES
OF THOSE TEXT MESSAGES, THE THEN
WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF MARK
MEADOWS, WALDRON WHO WAS COOKING
UP THIS PLOT TO ACCESS VOTING
MACHINES IN SWING STATES.
WHAT IS THE LEGAL SIGNIFICANCE
OR LIABILITY FOR MEADOWS TO BE
AWARE OF AN ATTEMPT TO ACCESS
AND PERHAPS INTERFERE WITH
VOTING MACHINES?
>> SO MARK MEADOWS HAS LONG BEEN
THE KIND OF KEY TO A POTENTIAL
COOPERATOR WHO COULD BLOW THIS
WHOLE THING OPEN, RIGHT?
HE'S PRIVY TO WHAT TRUMP KNEW,
HE IS REALLY THE FUNNEL KIND OF
FOR INFORMATION COMING INTO THE
WHITE HOUSE AND GOING OUT FROM
TRUMP TO OTHER PEOPLE.
SO ANY PRESSURE THAT COULD BE
PUT ON MARK MEADOWS THAT PUTS
HIM IN JEOPARDY THAT INFLUENCES
HIM TO COOPERATE IS IMPORTANT.
AND THIS STRIKES ME AS SOMETHING
LIKE THAT.
HERE IS AN INSTANCE WHERE YOU
HAVE SOMEONE VERY DEEPLY
INVOLVED IN THESE POTENTIALLY
ILLEGAL SCHEMES TO ACCESS VOTING
INFORMATION AND IT'S NOT JUST
THROUGH SIDNEY POWELL AND RUDY
GIULIANI AND MIKE FLYNN AND
THOSE FOLKS BUT DIRECTLY TO MARK
MEADOWS.
THAT TO ME IS A PRESSURE POINT
THAT YOU CAN USE TO SAY TO MARK
MEADOWS, LISTEN, YOU NEED TO
COME ON BOARD AND COOPERATE AND
TELL US WHAT YOU KNOW AND THAT
OF COURSE COULD BE A TREASURE
TROVE.
>> I WANT TO ASK YOU BIG PICTURE
HERE.
THIS IS THE QUESTION I GET MOST
OFTEN FROM FAMILY AND FRIENDS
LOOKING AT THESE VARIOUS
INVESTIGATIONS.
LET'S FOCUS ON JANUARY 6.
WEDNESDAY THE LAST PUBLIC
HEARINGS.
WE HAVE HAD MANY PUBLIC
HEARINGS, MANY IMPORTANT
REVELATIONS THE QUESTION OF
COURSE IS NOW WHAT HAPPENS WITH
IT.
WILL THERE BE A CRIMINAL
REFERRAL, FOR EXAMPLE.
YOU SPENT YEARS AS A PROSECUTOR.
DO YOU SEE THE EVIDENCE HERE?
HAVE THEY MADE THE CASE FOR
CRIMINAL REFERRAL FOR ANYONE UP
TO AND INCLUDING THE FORMER
PRESIDENT?
>> WELL, CERTAINLY THEY'VE MADE
THE CASE FOR A REFERRAL AND IN
FACT WE KNOW THAT DOJ IS ALREADY
INVESTIGATING PARTS OF THIS PLOT
AT LEAST SO TO BE HONEST THE
REFERRAL ISN'T PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT TO DOJ.
THEY ARE ALREADY LOOKING AT
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
WHAT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO DOJ IS
THE EVIDENCE THAT HAS BEEN
AMASSED BY THE COMMITTEE AND
IT'S BEEN VERY POWERFUL AND
IMPRESSIVE.
SO THEY ARE ALREADY LOOKING INTO
THIS.
THERE IS SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE OF
AN ILLEGAL SCHEME.
THE QUESTION IS WHEN THEY PUT IT
ALL TOGETHER WILL THEY CHARGE OR
NOT IN THEIR DISCRETION AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ALL WAITING TO
HEAR OF COURSE.
>> THE FORMER PRESIDENT SEEMS TO
BE UNDER THE IMPRESSION THAT IF
AND WHEN HE ANNOUNCES HIS
CANDIDACY FOR 2024 THAT HE IS
LESS LIKELY TO BE INDICTED.
IS THAT TRUE?
>> NO.
NOT AT ALL.
I MEAN, IF WE GOT TO WITHIN 60
FACE OF AN ELECTION WE KNOW THAT
THE UNWRITTEN RULE AT DOJ IS
THAT THEY WOULDN'T BRING A
CHARGE IN THAT PERIOD, BUT JUST
BECAUSE YOU'VE BEEN ANNOUNCED AS
A CANDIDATE DOESN'T MEAN THAT
YOU WON'T BE INVESTIGATED.
INDEED, IF HE REALLY THOUGHT
THAT WERE TRUE I THINK HE WOULD
HAVE ANNOUNCED ALREADY TO PUT A
STOP TO ALL OF THIS.
SO I BELIEVE THAT HE KNOWS THAT
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
CERTAINLY MERRICK GARLAND ISN'T
PAYING ANY ATTENTION TO THAT
JEAN EVERY RODGERS, THANKS SO
MUCH.